is this thing on yes it is because I hit
the button yeah [ __ ] how's it going
guys so today I will talk about this
small little uh habit I have of mine or
what I call a sickness it's a shoe body
sickness and I think the last time that
I had this conversation with you I told
you that wasn't stop buying shoes I
[ __ ] mine not so much to say that I'm
not into shoes anymore because I am but
I did sell a majority of them recently
why because I believe like shoe
collecting for me has become such a fad
or not even that it's just it's not the
same that it used to be you know back in
the day when we used to copies kicks we
used to copy just because it looked dope
you know nowadays just like if you
collect shoes you're the cool guy of the
block oh oh you got the haints on your
feet oh I think I bet you this before in
the previous vlog but I actually wanted
George because I thought that they can
make me duck like a black man hmm did it
happen there's none of your [ __ ]
business but one of the request is
actually came in is for me to review
shoes now I'm not gonna go ahead and
make my channel about reviewing shoes
but I am going to give you guys a little
bit of perspective on the shoes that I
do like to wear on a regular basis you
know funny enough when I was actually
considering doing shoe review videos I
looked up a lot of people who do shoe
reviews and you guys are boring as [ __ ]
every single do that there's a shoe
review on YouTube either solid they just
spoke up they're [ __ ] high or they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about this shoe right here is made up of
material with the Department we scratch
it make a noise and you sound like you
[ __ ] have a sleep I chop my feet
before I buy the shoes that you wear
here's a little tip for you guys out
there that want to do these vlogs you
got to stop trying to be cool you know
I'm saying like we're a little bit too
laid-back language is Yong Yong Canyon
he can take me it could be a butt naked
girl blowing like that me my dick fall
asleep the let's start with one of my
personal favorites that I have in my
recent rotation Nike Air Thomas now I'm
not exactly too sure how to pronounce
that she was either Thomas or tetanus
depending if you want to be classy or
you wanna be hood tennis just like that
dude you saw on a tease video this is
done as you may know [ __ ] this is I
don't know what the [ __ ] to say it's
okay it's just something sweet for the
[ __ ] kids okay now Thomas's are
really great because number one if you
gotta look at it design-wise it's a mix
between I say a Roshi and also in Air
Max 1 or 94 a lot of the recent shoes
that I've been wearing one of the bigger
factors that I
is ventilation and this shoe definitely
hasn't summertime it gets hot so I need
something to keep my toes nice and fresh
because you don't want to smell somebody
speak after it comes out of a door at
11:00 patent leather is stinky feet up
next we had the airmax one picnics
airmax wants to me is a classic it's
never gonna go out of style
much like the Air Max 90 and it has a
lot of history to it I think the air
next one was the very first shoe to
actually have the back bubble in it I
think he came out on 1987 know my [ __ ]
like I'm a [ __ ] shoe historian in
1987 this shoe but if you want to talk
about the material in the shoe it's kind
of like a cloth denim / chambray type of
thing I don't I'm not exactly sure what
chambray is but that sounds right
something somebody's ghetto cousin [ __ ]
Chevron I was actually introduced to
this shoe by Bart and I told that fool
that I was never gonna buy another shoe
again and then well look at what I got
it and if you guys want to know why this
is called the mmx1 picnics it's because
what pop the interior if you look at it
it's a picnic blanket and inside the
Nike epilim is actually a picnic
disposable plate it's pretty cute huh
that's right Menten cos she's cute and
still be a man if killed mmm sure right
now the third shoe that's coming up is
probably one of the shoes that I have
worn the most it is the adidas ultra
boost now for me I haven't really been
to much of an adidas fan because I think
design wise they've been kind of lacking
in the last like six or seven years
however you do have these ultra boost
now design wise I can't say anything
that I hate about this I love the way it
looks it breeds very well because
obviously it's ventilated the way it
fits on you is very snug because the
material is kind of like a neoprene
sleeve it has an attached heel tab and
also the tongue is attached this shoe as
well which kind of goes back to how it
fits like a glove now I know what you
think for those of you out there who
know this shoe knows how [ __ ]
expensive this thing is and yes about
140 to 180 dollars depending on whether
that you get yes I understand that
sometimes you need groceries but for me
I was like hey I'm fat I could use a
little yo less food so [ __ ] it aside
from the design the biggest reason why I
got this shoe was because of how
comfortable it is and I know I've told
you guys that I'm a huge fan of Nike
Roshi's Nike Roshi's don't even come
close to this now if you're thinking
about value wise with comfort the Nike
Roshi definitely wins because in bro
she's you can get them as cheap as up to
60 bucks if you get an online fan retail
they go roughly about
seventy so yeah you could probably buy
close to two-and-a-half Roshi's for one
of these I don't know why the [ __ ] you
were gonna have a shoe but so with those
things coupled up the row she's
definitely are better by but when it
comes to material and comfort you're not
going to beat these shoes right here but
interesting ly enough I mean I'm not
sure if you guys knew this but you know
I was never really what you call rich or
I never had a lot of money but one of
the ways that I actually got to LA
because I had no cash I could sell all
my shoes not plan you didn't quit when
you have a ghetto child sell his shoes
that he worked really hard for working a
job that had minimum wage I almost had a
holiday I almost knocked the [ __ ] out
but I kind of got over and it was very
nice at the moment when I you know when
I had that ability to to kind of get the
things that I want not the things that I
need cuz you know when you're broke like
all your money goes into necessities
whether it's bills electricity food
whatever your money is is a means of
survival not a means of pleasure and uh
you know I never really had that
opportunity you know as happy as it did
make me it was really stupid
it wasn't even for a fashion purpose it
was kinda filled that inner like ghetto
child need that I always wanted to get
the shoes that I that I've coveted my
whole life when you wet like the dopest
kicks it was like a form of respect
almost like people would like look at
you and say you know what that dude like
the Jordan Levin's he's tight let's Rob
the [ __ ] it's kind of interesting when
you look back and see how far you've
come like I had the ability to buy
things that I want and that's very odd I
know at the same time like you know I
can help out my family and uh it's a
blessing man you know a lot of the
reasons why I even get to do what I get
to do is obviously because of you guys
so you know you know I always thank you
for watching and like continuing to
support me and I'm glad that I could
make you laugh and make your days better
or hopefully I can if not then what the
[ __ ] you keep on watching my channel but
yeah man I gotta say life's good and I'm
gonna keep on working harder so stay
tuned to the next episode I don't know
what to say this is getting really
awkward love you I'm a jackoff
you